Speaker 1: We have seen a lot of things get
kind of wacky and backwards in the aftermath
of Joe Biden pulling troops from Afghanistan.
And, of course, that created a vacuum in which
the Taliban has retaken control of the country.
Now, I'm not going to redo yesterday's segment
where I outlined my position on this in full.
But in short, I agree with Joe Biden's decision.
I said this yesterday.
I think there would have been chaos whenever
we ultimately left Afghanistan.
But the Afghanistan incursion has been a failure.
More U.S. involvement for more time wouldn't
help anything.
The longer we stay, the more money is spent
to ultimately achieve nothing.
Our involvement is a negative.
It's not a positive.
And one of the things that we're seeing is
all sorts of people on the left, on the right,
for different reasons now say we have to go
back into Afghanistan.
That's one thing we're seeing.
There's all of a sudden people saying, no,
we got to go back.
It was a mistake to leave.
We've got to do more nation building and peacekeeping
and world policing and all this stuff.
Let's go back in.
That's weird.
But another of the strange things we're seeing,
and I'm not even saying I know what to make
of it, but another thing we're seeing is some
really bizarre, kind of like revisionist histories
and apologizing for the Taliban, which is
now taking control.
Now, I will be the first to admit the Taliban
is more complicated than just like one explanation,
like Sharia law.
OK, well, I mean, Sharia law can mean different
things in different countries, but there are
now some people framing the Taliban as sort
of like maybe kind of good.
And I'm finding it really weird.
And today we're going to look at a clip of
British Chief of Defense Staff General Sir
Nick Carter.
That's actually his title.
I'm not like doing the sir routine, General
Sir Nick Carter, who was on Sky News talking
about kind of like the Taliban is not that
bad.
And so let's just get into it, check out the
words he uses and how he describes the Taliban.
Now, Carter was in Afghanistan in 2004, commanding
British troops there had additional deployments
to Afghanistan.
And remember, the Taliban is a radical group
considered a terrorist group by multiple governments,
including Canada, Turkey and others.
The U.S. has never recognized the Taliban
government, although I don't believe the U.S.
considers the Taliban a terrorist group Trump
was just negotiating with the months ago.
So here we go.
Let's take a look and check this out.
Speaker 2: And how do you feel about collaborating
with the enemy when they have carried out
such atrocities against U.S. military personnel
base?
Speaker 3: I think you have to be very careful
using the word enemy.
I think people need to understand who the
Taliban actually are and of course, what they
are, a disparate collection of tribes people,
as President Karzai put it to me only yesterday,
the country boys.
And the plain fact is that they happen to
live by a code of honor.
Speaker 1: So these are these are tribes people,
their country boys, and they live by a code
of honor, almost implying like that's a good
thing on its face.
Now, code of honor, code of honor can be anything.
You can have a code of honor that is horrifying.
And there are many examples of that.
But he continues to sort of say this is not
good.
This is maybe not so bad of a group
Speaker 3: to stand it, which has been the
standard for many, many years.
It's called Pashtunwali.
It has honor at the heart of what they do.
They are bound together by a common purpose,
which is they don't like corrupt governance,
they don't like governance that is self-serving
and they want an Afghanistan that is inclusive
for all.
Speaker 1: Wow.
I mean, that that's sounding pretty good,
right?
I mean, it's all about honor.
These are country boys.
They're very much against corruption.
Will corruptions bad?
So being against corruption must be good and
they're for inclusion.
I mean, that's all pretty good stuff right
now.
While in power in Afghanistan, when you look
at the history, the Taliban became notorious
for their misogyny and their violence against
women, period, forcing full burqa wearing
at all at all times, systematic gender segregation,
women not allowed to work, women not allowed
to be educated past age eight, only allowed
to go to a male doctor if they have a male
chaperon to take them.
Public floggings and executions for women
for violating Taliban law, occasionally forcing
into child marriage.
And on and on and on.
So maybe he's saying it would be different
now or something.
But but we don't actually have reason to think
that that's the case.
So let's continue here.
Speaker 3: So I think rather than talking
about women, but except women.
Well, again, I think we have to wait and see.
I mean, I don't know what they mean.
Speaker 2: I'll support that the way that
they treat women, actually.
Speaker 3: Well, I think you have to listen
to what they're saying at the moment.
And I think you have to listen to the facts
on the ground saying they are justified
Speaker 1: by what they're saying is using
this coded language about the involvement
of women in.
Society as dictated by religious law, right,
and so you have to be you have to understand
that that's an extraordinarily cynical way
to talk about inclusion.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
And I'm not saying that's anything that you
and I would approve of, particularly.
I'm just.
But I do find that.
Absolutely.
But I do.
Speaker 1: And I'll go back just a second,
because Sharia law is mentioned here, acts
on the
Speaker 3: ground saying they are justified.
So, yeah, and I'm not saying that's anything
that you and I would approve of particularly.
I'm just not.
Absolutely.
But I do think that they have changed.
I think they recognize that over the course
of the last 20 years, Afghanistan has evolved.
They recognize the fundamental role that women
have played in that evolution.
And, yes, they at the moment will undoubtedly
say that they want to respect women's rights
under Islamic law, and that will be a Sharia
law.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that they
won't allow them to be involved in government
and in education and in medicine and those
things that they need them to be involved
in.
Speaker 1: Now, I don't want to just slam
this guy like there is.
There's an aspect of this that I think, you
know, we I am not for Sharia law.
I'm not for any religious law being the government
law, civil law, OK?
No matter what it is, I don't want the Christian
version of Sharia that some of these right
wingers want in the US.
I don't mean I'm against Sharia law, but if
we're going to have a more nuanced understanding
of this, Sharia can mean different things
in different places.
And we have to understand that, like, for
example, there's full Sharia criminal law,
which is outrageous.
I mean, just completely outrageous.
There's also Sharia law, like in Egypt, where
the penal and civil codes are basically based
on 19th century French law, as in as is the
case in many parts of the world.
But but there is Sharia law in the country
in some more general religious going to mix
with the government.
But the penal code, the civil law is still
is still based on 19th century French law.
So the point here is it's true that Sharia
law is not one thing, but there's no reason
to think based on the history of the Taliban,
that they would go in the direction of Egypt.
Historically, the Taliban has gone more in
the direction of full Sharia criminal law.
Let's let's look just the last few seconds
of this clip.
Speaker 3: So I think we have to be patient.
We have to give them the space to show how
they are going to step up to the plate and
whether or not we can work with them will
very much depend upon how they treat all Afghans.
Speaker 1: OK, so it's sort of just like a
weird soft apologetics for the Taliban.
And this is just one example.
And to be clear, I'm not saying the Taliban's
bad, so we got to send troops and no, I'm
glad the troops are coming out, even though
some now went back in.
We talked about that yesterday.
But some of the weird apologetics that we're
seeing for the Taliban, absent any reason
to think that the Taliban has really changed.
I just find bizarre.
So I want to hear from you about this.
We're going to have more coverage of this
story on The David Pakman Show Instagram,
which you can find at The David Pakman Show.
While you're there.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.